et vendredi dernier serge morvan préfet
des yvelines et plus de 300 pompiers du
département étaient rassemblés à la
préfecture dans le cadre de la journée
nationale des sapeurs pompiers
cette journée c'est l'occasion de rendre
hommage aux hommes qui ont créé les
corps départementaux d'incendié et de
secours d'honorer les personnel méritant
mais aussi de rendre hommage aux décédé
en service cinq soldats du feu ont perdu
la vie en service cette année je le
rappelle
écoutez les précisions du colonel
patrick et sécardin il était au micro de
william l cette année est une année
heureusement le nombre de victimes était
le plus bas niveau historique
c'est un travail de prévention que nous
faisons depuis des années qui tend à
faire diminuer effectivement les décès
en service depuis effectivement
de nombreux mois le pays est en
difficultés dues aux attentes à une
prévention par rapport à l'euro 2016 aux
inondations et nos services sont
extrêmement sollicités mais les
personnels répond toujours présent avec
autant effectivement d'ardeur à défendre
des valeurs de la république